seems
intentional
good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy hump day
it's um don't forget to hump someone you
love
and in the spirit of hum day do do do do
do is here
we miss him so much i really did miss
him seeing him this morning was
such a sweet treat that's what he does
surprise and delight
surprise delights humps period
and you should do the same today on this
glorious hump day here in manhattan
yes um we have a great show for you
today we actually have so much to cover
five past five of course of course real
housewives of new york episode last
night and the real housewives of dallas
finale which i'm
pretty sure you didn't watch i didn't i
tapped out it was so bad
um and then we also have deer toasters
which is our advice segment so
i just feel like this is going to be
almost if not longer than an hour
and i'm just grateful to be alive
grateful to be alive
though i just have a lot on my mind
today and on my heart i'm so upset about
what's going on in israel like
hundreds of rockets are being
thrown at israel from gaza it's so
upsetting and what's
maybe more upsetting is the response
from
the media and celebrities in america who
think that they
are political science experts
um i'm just i'm in shock no what's
really upsetting
to me is honestly at the end of the day
and i really do believe this like
everyone is entitled to their opinion
and if you if that's your opinion like i
do respect it i really do
but the vitriol coming my way
so deep rooted in anti-semitism whether
it's in an overt way or like in a subtle
way that's what's really scary and i
feel like we've been saying this for a
while like
there is like there's this pass for
anti-semitism
in our media in our country in our
rhetoric and it's just really coming to
light lots of anti-semites just showing
their
their vibes in these past few days and i
just really
i'm not going to tell anyone how to feel
i feel very strongly on the side of
israel and that's
my prerogative um i just really
encourage you guys to
look at legitimate sources bella hadid
is not a legitimate source
influencers we're not legitimate sources
we are not
no so instagram graphics like are not
legitimate sources this is like
years centuries long conflict that can't
be summed up in an instagram graphic and
you know what it's actually
okay to be ignorant about it and not
know really what's going on
but what's not okay is just to post
something because
something and spread misinformation
knowing that you don't really know
what's going on so emily radakowski like
we weren't waiting for your thoughts on
the israeli-palestinian conflict
no and actually the conflict will go on
despite your instagram story despite my
instagram story as well
that i'm any different typically when it
comes to posting instagram stories about
things that are going on
um my my mentality is when i feel like
no one is saying something that i feel
compelled to speak and before i posted i
had not seen one influencer
who was standing with israel israel is
the only democracy in the middle east
they are the only safe place for the
lgbtq plus community in the middle east
they have a pride parade it is
it's so it's layered it's layered it's
layered if you stand for human rights if
you stand for women's rights if you
stand for lgbtq
plus rights i don't see how you don't
stand with israel
no 100 percent your your wokeness is
contradicting itself
yeah also um i watched a segment uh that
trevor noah did on it and
his overall message i did not agree with
but he did make a really good point
because this is
like i said so layered um and you could
just pick up
you know any day and and want to take a
side of the conflict
and you could you can't just start three
days ago and be like oh
israel is wrong like you can you don't
know what's
unless you keep up with what's been
going on you could just pick up any day
and say one side is right and one side
is wrong
so just please stop like it's really
it's offensive
that's also the issue with the media
where there are rockets being launched
into israel for
days now and when israel defends itself
then it's a story israel launches
rockets into gaza
right what about the hundreds that
proceeded it only retaliates like
israel only defends itself and the way
that i
see it is that if israel's enemies laid
down their weapons
there would be peace if israel laid down
yes yes sorry if israel's enemies laid
down their weapons there would be peace
if israel laid down
their weapons there would be no israel
yeah i'm just seeing a lot of
contradictory double standards and it's
really been difficult to be on social
media in the last
48 hours but um sorry i'm not sorry
and i support israel we support israel
don't get it twisted this is our show
yeah this is not anyone else's show
this is our show and i do i respect
other people's opinions and all i ask is
that my
opinions are respected and i don't think
that's asking a lot and calling me a
white supremacist when i'm literally a
jewish person
is so [ __ ] that's funny it's like
calling the jews who stand with israel
nazis
do you know what what's up history look
it up sweetie
do you know what the white supremacists
think of jews not fondly
not just please like it's really
annoying i respect your opinion please
respect mine and leave me the [ __ ] alone
okay
you're more than welcome to unfollow me
like i can't stress that enough right
and it's okay
to not be super informed just don't go
around
posting graphics like you are yeah and
the graphics are killing me like they're
so
stupid and they're so not based in fact
they're not they don't have sources no
it it
it's crazy the things that i've been
seeing are so shocking to me this idea
that like israel is
like a colonial settler when israel
is a country that goes by the same name
that speaks the same language that
follows the same religion as it has for
thousands of years since the literal
bible
bible bible um i don't want to get in my
soapbox too much but
i don't either but i really feel like
and i think especially for
toasters and a lot of people listening
like they genuinely are like how can
vanessa hudgens be saying this and you
guys are saying this like
how is it so different different it's
two different
sets of facts 100 so
i just feel like because no one else
literally
no one else is going to take up for
israel it is our job
yes i stand with you sis and i stand
with israel
therefore we both actually i think i'm
sitting with you i'm not really much a
stander
that works too claude um great show
today
fast five a good amount of stuff
happened over the
last 24 hours there was a businessman
bow engagement there was and we'll be
talking about it we really will i just
want to share with everyone that i did
something this morning that i think is
worthy of sharing
okay this morning i rose and i groaned
i woke up early and i worked out because
we're going on a trip i've been on a
really good
cadence of wellness and i just wanted
one last like
push before we have a great weekend and
so
i feel like really proud of myself
because i'm not a morning person let
alone a workout in the morning person
and i did it she wrote i did not rose
or groan today i just kind of stumble i
didn't have time you just groaned i just
didn't even get my coffee like i'm just
dead you know
oh my god that's so sad i've just been
doing a lot getting ready for our trip
we have a spray tan like
i know it doesn't sound like a lot but
it is a lot of the packing so i just
like honestly i couldn't take on any
more
trauma okay and the coffee is like
starting to traumatize me the anxiety
and the jitters like that finger thing
yesterday that was crazy but i also
think it's the pressure of this tic tac
series like you have so much
people are waiting you're taking on way
too much i am and you know what's this
the toast in 60 seconds how does she do
it all so i am going to take a brief
pause like for just a few days until we
get back from nashville um
on the coffee series you're gonna lay
off the sauce i'm laying off the sauce
temporarily
okay well i guess without further ado do
where are you right here because it's
someday here are the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
siesta key in the hills new beginnings
they are back on mtv wednesday may 12th
starting at 8 pm
that is today what's going on in siesta
key juliet is living the lavish life
with her boyfriend sam who is a
billionaire but will kelsey rain on
their parade when they clash over their
rival swimsuit brands
and this season brandon chloe madison
amanda and garrett are trying to move
forward but will their past pull them
back under
while siesta key is embracing the
unknown the hills new beginnings is all
about moving forward
heidi and spencer's relationship is put
to the test as they realize they're on
two different pages
when it comes to having another baby
brody and audrina are back in the dating
pool but as they start seeing other
people they begin to realize that they
may be ready to be more than just
friends
justin bobby reaches out to reconnect
with his estranged family as he looks to
his past
in order to settle down and plan for his
future plus a long-awaited reunion
years in the making with a former
castmate you'll have to see to believe
with this hollywood will this hollywood
crew be able to begin again
find out during the season premieres of
siesta key and the hills new beginnings
starting wednesday may 12th at 8 only on
mtv that's tonight wednesday may 12th on
mtv
love it i am truly so excited okay as
well
are you ready for our first story yeah
taylor swift and olivia rodrigo
finally meet in person at the brit
awards last night were the brit awards
and
they looked fabulous they did look
fabulous and they looked fun
and poppin and lit and little mix was
there with their two
pregnant bed bellies and there was 2 500
people i think there were frontline
workers
in the audience and i don't believe that
they were wearing masks so it was really
just like a sight to see
yeah i mean it's it's very exciting it's
crazy
olivia rodrigo meeting taylor swift
finally as you all know the journey like
superfan
taylor really supported her from early
days of driver's license and now they're
together
which is sort of confirming snitch's
theory that she has that when killer
does
go on tour olivia rodriguez is going to
open for her yes it was very exciting
seeing the culmination of like a
social media relationship finally hit
the big time
i hope it was like as good irl for them
as it was online did you see that olivia
rodrigo had like
a bunch of handwritten notes that she
gave to people taylor got one harry
styles got one
and harry styles left his on the table
when we left
that is like really traumatizing i know
but i feel like olivia rodrigo had the
best night of her life and i'm just so
happy for her because she deserves it
i agree with that and her album's coming
out oh
and as kind of like a supplemental story
is
like maybe like two days ago joshua
baskett came out i believe is bisexual
or
queer i'm not 100 sure um what he
identifies as but
that was a big story too just like
another development in this very complex
love triangle once again
it's layered it is very layered ongoing
and
are him and serena still together see i
don't know and like
i just need to close this chapter and i
don't think i can do that without
getting like a final confirmation on
their relationship like was it worth all
of this
i don't know i feel like they're not
together i haven't seen a picture of
that i don't know how they could be
unless it's true love
unless it's true love which in which in
that case this whole saga would have
been worth it for them and it would have
been okay
yeah for sure but one never knows one
never knows
next story is some really crazy tv news
ellen degeneres is ending her talk show
she says it's just not a challenge
anymore
ellen is signing off that's why
daytime's most recognizable face has
decided her upcoming season the show's
19th will be the last
the decision which fell to ellen is said
to have been several years in the making
she informed her staff on may 11th and
will sit down with longtime pal and
daytime predecessor oprah
to discuss the news on ellen's may 13th
show
she said when you're a creative person
you constantly need to be challenged and
as great as the show is
and as fun as it is it's just not a
challenge anymore she told the hollywood
reporter yeah so i'm just like not going
to believe that i'm going to choose not
to believe that
i mean this is there's been talks about
ellen like ending her show but she
always persevered on and i do think like
this enormous scandal that she went
through at the beginning of the year or
last year um definitely contributed to
it but i actually have a lot of respect
for her for like not going out in a low
she did do i don't know what her ratings
are like i don't watch her show but she
did come back she did recover she
apologized
and now she can go out with some dignity
and i do respect that i do
i agree and everything must come to an
end at some point and 19 is a lot
i imagine it's not challenging anymore
and it's also not fun
i imagine it's definitely not fun but i
don't know ever like how challenging it
really was
you know yeah well everything is a
challenge
just when you're starting out you know
yeah you know you're doing like new
things and you feel like you're really
doing something but i just i'm sure
you know it's time for a change but with
her new show
that i was talking about earlier this
week ellen's next big designer
the show's really good yeah and i'm sure
she has a lot of projects like that and
she works on a lot of things behind the
scenes
again it's weird that it's like ellen's
next top designer even though she's not
even on the show that i've seen but
that's the thing like with celebrities
now like why would ellen go into a
studio every day and
like film for hours when literally she
could attach her name to something and
probably make just as much money
yeah and then she could go live in her
mansion with porsha and just like save
animals but some people also like love
the fame like the forward-facing
part yes but i do think after you know
so many years in the industry like
that's not
that's no longer it loses its luster
yeah
yeah so this is really interesting i do
think and we were talking about this
earlier how
i think kelly clarkson is gonna be like
the next ellen like to me when i'm
thinking who's thriving in the daytime
space
it's kelly clarkson i can't even think
of anyone else and they are both on nbc
right
i think so so i just think that like one
small step for ellen won largely for
kelly clarkson
i guess so you know it's big like yeah
ellen owned daytime for so long people
came people went the meredith vieira
show the chris show the bethany show
the harry connick jr show justice for
that one tyra
she was successful for a while but ellen
kind of like owned it and now it's like
there's gonna be a new queen
is it gonna be kelly clarkson yes it is
does she deserve it
yes she does i put my money on kelly
every day yeah every way
i'm not putting my money on drew
barrymore just not
no kelly or best kelly or buck kelly to
the moon
kelly to the moon are you ready for our
next story a little happy couple news
with the businessman bow
it's a little happy couple news with the
businessman bow
caitlyn bristow screams for joy in
proposal video shared by jason tardik he
says it was the reaction i was hoping
for
caitlyn let out a few happy screams when
jason asked her to marry him he
surprised
the former bachelorette by proposing to
her monday while recording an episode of
her podcast off the vine
i really hope she uses it as a podcast
of course she's going to get like a neil
lane sponsorship or like a
the knot you know and make it like a
wedding central
yeah they don't even have to do that
because so many people are going to tune
in because also
it's crazy that like his engage his
proposal speech
was recorded most people like you take
the pictures after
you never really hear what the person
says during the proposal it's a very
intimate moment
and it's so blacked out usually i forget
so it's usually like a moment in time
that's kind of lost
so it's pretty cool that they have it
recorded i lo i mean
i think we've all known that this was
like otp forever and it was just a
matter of them doing it on their own
time and i'm
so happy for them they are the true
culmination of businessman beau and i'm
just
thrilled kaitlyn looked gorgeous she
like recently dyed her hair back to dark
and she had like a sickening manicure
and it was just like kind of a perfect
moment you know begs the question like
did she know you know no i agree but
then also they came at us
prepared like they didn't just post the
minute it happened they got some
tasteful shots done they had shots of
the ring she had her sweet manicure
she had like a look with like that was
more bridal so
i feel like this happened a few days ago
and then they were getting their ducks
in order for the announcement i actually
really appreciate
the planning me too the ring is so
stunning and that's what happens
when you have a businessman just another
reason to get
a businessman bow it is huge it's
gorgeous not to be annoying so much
better than a first one and
i'm just i'm thrilled for them they
really are like a great couple
and it's a beautiful story you know they
found love in a hopeless place
yeah they really did it's a beautiful
story i
agree like it was never a matter of like
are they gonna get engaged it's just
like oh one's gonna be their time it
wasn't a matter of if but just a matter
of when
yeah so i'm really happy for them i'm so
happy for caitlin and this is just gonna
be an exciting next chapter
caitlyn's just the kind of gal who like
deserves a happy ending you know yes
happy ending i mean not like the massage
but we all deserve happy endings i think
we
all deserve happy endings yeah instead
denise richards
and victoria justice they collapsed on
that one
um yeah this is a very sweet story
it's great i'm so happy for them mazel
tov
our next story is the latest in las
vegas residencies
wait the latest in las vegas residency
residencies brought to you by nuts.com
yep we have found an incredible website
that you guys have to check out
nuts.com is the best kept secret of
savvy snackers across the country
they have a variety of really high
quality snacks they're all super
delicious whether you like
dried fruits nuts they have chocolate
like they really have everything and
there's
every something for everyone um and it's
not just for nut lovers it's your one
stop online pantry shop
so um like the pantry aisle has become
quite mundane if you're looking for more
elevated snacks
some more what's the word um
eclectic variety of choices you gotta
check out nuts.com the simple and
convenient way to have nutritious
delicious
superstitious healthy nuts dried fruit
flowers grains and so many other high
quality foods delivered straight to your
door
they have healthy kid-friendly snacks
like dried strawberries custom trail mix
plus they have all the raw organic
roasted salted and candied nuts you can
imagine they even have chocolate dipped
which are my personal favorite
on the websites easy to navigate they
have great photos of all the products
you know exactly what you're getting
and it is a family-run business that
takes pride in getting you the freshest
products available fresh to death they
also have gluten-free and vegan options
available
delivery is super fast most orders ship
on the same
day they have fresher products than the
supermarket so if you want to check it
out go to
newnuts.com customers can get free
shipping on their first order
when you text toast to 64 000. so
text t-o-a-s-t to 64 000 to get free
shipping on your first order from
nuts.com
that's toast to 64 000 terms apply
available at nuts.com
terms love it i love nuts.com now i'm
hungry i need a little
snack katy perry luke bryan and carrie
underwood
land las vegas residencies let's see
katy perry luke bryan
carrie underwood are ready to call las
vegas their new home so they have a deal
with american idol clearly
yeah or um but it's just
weird that all three of them like oh i
guess carrie underwood is american
yeah yeah the music superstars announced
wednesday that they will be founding
headliners at the theater at resorts
world a 5 000 seat venue
on the las vegas strip where they will
launch concert residences beginning in
december
so i have to say even though katy
perry's music over the last like five
years has been
pretty disgraceful she does have a
sickening catalog of music
that is perfect for vegas i saw her
prism tour
and it was literally a traveling vegas
residency it was
gorgeous the songs the sets the light up
outfits like it was a residency in the
making and i do think
she is going to kill it like she's
perfect for it
for sure i would definitely go and see
her residency
she has so much early music that's
iconic
incredible and then even the newer stuff
so many
so many misses but there's a few that
like okay i could get down to this
daisies daisy's even you know what's
grown on me because i think cody riggsby
likes it he plays it sometimes does it
change to the rhythm
no but that has grown on me because it's
a good spinning song because when we're
all like this we're chained to the
rhythm we're literally chained to the
rhythm that's
that was really off-key chained to the
ring it's honestly the worst song bonap
the teeth
the worst yeah that's the one cody plays
it sometimes
but what other song is growing on you
that's the one bon appetit
it's growing it's not growing on me but
cody sometimes plays it and i have to
listen to it that's
it and i do listen to it no jackie i
know
i know i know daisies is so good like
for me that was her
redemption are the katy stamps gonna
come after us
i mean once again that's me like at one
point in my life like i was so
you were obsessed actually the first
concert i ever went to
was katy perry i was actually honestly a
die-hard number one fan and it was
before she was playing
it was a tiny theater it was irving ring
possible yeah it was like the hot and
cold i think you went with alex
personality i did and she's a toaster we
always talk about her
um it was honestly the best concert ever
like we were dying me and alex like
living our best [ __ ] lives and it was
like she only had released like hot and
cold and i kissed a girl like that was
all we knew
yeah plus her super bowl halftime show
was so [ __ ] good that it's just like
setting her up for fantastic residency i
feel really good about this
me too in general she's also cemented
into like a pop icon hall of fame
because of that super bowl halftime show
like for
us i feel like of course the critics
like they don't like it i don't think so
well the thing is
if the critics don't like something that
means it's good it means it's creme de
la creme means cream no some of you are
still from new jersey no no honestly
creme de la creme
is what let's be real the critics love
the creme de la creme and that's like
the sophisticated [ __ ] nobody likes i
like heavy cream
that's what the mass americans like
you like but are you following my logic
yes yes like the fancy elite
that the critics love like the lobster
the critics love the movie lobster
that is [ __ ] like i like the [ __ ] that
the critics hate but that america loves
yeah that's kind of like what kevin hart
was saying about his movie
yes night school yeah even though i know
you didn't like that movie i didn't but
maybe it was me like maybe i was just in
a bad head space
that i know i every time we talk about
this we have the same conversation
because i was in a really bad head space
when i saw baby boss 2 and i just know
it's a good movie and i walked out of
the theater but i should have given it a
chance
i never saw two but i saw one and i
really liked that one and also think
like a man to
think like a man one is one of my
favorite movies like it's actually me
and olivia's like favorite movie
together
it is so good and i was just looking at
a mood in the theater when i saw the
second one i'm like this is trash but
it's like not
yeah it's stellar filmmaking nice
just saying okay our next vegas
residency luke bryan i know we talk
mad [ __ ] about luke bryan on the show
but like not yeah we do we're always
like talentless hack like
it always goes to luke bryan like what
about luke combs yeah like he's like
with like jason we're just like we don't
get it they're just like played out
mainstream country stars right but i
recently saw
my timehop us like going so hard for
luke bryan
at stagecoach and it was an amazing he
did an amazing set like
and in that moment i remember feeling
like okay i get it
so i just need to go back to there and
be like i get this
got a little boom in my big truck gonna
open up the doors and turn it up
and the georgia bus you're gonna watch
me making you fall in love get up on the
hood of my
daddy's tractor up on the two guys it
don't matter down on the tailgate
girl i can't wait to watch you do your
thing shaking for the young boat
sticking in the hunky tongue for the
rednecks rock until i break it down
the dj cover that sunshine come on come
on come on
sugar bird chicken totally
shake it for the birds shake it for the
bees shake it for the catfish singing
down deep in the trees where the
crickets and the critters and the
squirrels shake it to the moon
shake it for me girl oh country girl
shake it for me
girl we are ready for nashville no we're
so ready that's how you agree
so [ __ ] good it is so redeeming it
makes up for
sunrise sunset
sunburn repeat that's so that is a
disgrace to music making so
i actually agree with you well i don't
think he deserves to win you know
entertainer of the year
vegas is a it's an interesting space and
i actually think he will
thrive but i would argue that
vegas requires entertainers of the year
maybe maybe but i would argue that vegas
shut up like honestly i hate arguing
with you you're so [ __ ] annoying
just shut up okay okay okay you know
what i was trying to say yes
i do know what you were trying to say if
maybe they just put some respect on luke
holmes's name once in a while we
wouldn't be so pressed about this and
maybe there would be a luke comes
[ __ ] residency and i would have to
move to vegas
move there every night imagine us seeing
luke combs every single night
that's like you have a bar you go to
every
like weekend in the city like that would
be our bar like nothing sounds better
nothing and then the other residency
that was announced was carrie
underwood oh did you not say lionel
richie
no i didn't you made it about american
idol yeah i did i i swear on my life i
heard you say lionel richie
maybe maybe i did um she'll never know
she's gonna be amazing amazing even
though the music she's putting out right
now
is of a different elk and it's very um
it's very elky no it's just um like
faith-based music and it's slow and it's
like in her field
but the thing is as two jewish queens we
stand faith-based faith-based music
franchesca
batelli i don't i can't say that as
telly
is a queen and i know i don't know if
you know this there's a trend going
around
on tick tock where people are sharing
their trauma with like church camp and
just like growing up in youth groups
but they're using a franchesca badass
television it's your life i've got a
couple dents in my fender
got a couple rips in my jeans and i
didn't even know that song
but the trend made me listen to it that
album
is so [ __ ] good and i do feel like
you can apply it to your god you know
i believe that you can as well and i
don't think it's blasphemous for us to
listen to it no i don't think so in some
of it it's just so like
self assuring like it's your life
what you gonna do what are you gonna do
it's your life the world is watching you
every day the choices you make
say what you are and who your heart
beats for
it's an open door it's your life
what you gonna do the world is watching
you
beautiful i agree honestly i think on
the plane today i'm gonna listen i'm
gonna get out the window but you're
gonna cry and listen to francesca
battistelli that's just that album
that's awkward because i'm gonna be like
sitting next to you if you're gonna be
crying what scene are you in um i'm in
the first row i'm in the third row so
okay so you have your privacy
yeah no but um margot flew home she was
in palm springs she flew home on may 5th
which is the anniversary
no it's our dad's birthday it would have
been his 65th birthday so it was just
like a
a really hard day and she was on the
plane
and in a window in a window she didn't
she texted me she's like i haven't had
like
every kid who's lost a parent knows like
there is a moment on like a special
anniversary
or on a birthday where you have a
[ __ ] breakdown and then you move on
with your day
and margot hadn't had the breakdown yet
because she was so busy in palm springs
and then she got on the plane and she
texted me she's like i'm freaking out
like
i just got on the plane i'm in a window
seat haven't had the obligatory
breakdown
i said just lean into it put your hood
on so nobody sees and takes a picture of
you
and you'll be fine yeah you know what
now that i think about it i haven't had
a breakdown in so long
like i'm due for a big one okay so and i
don't know when it's going to hit me
that's so scary it could catch me off
guard part of my trauma
is like there will be like days or weeks
that go by where i like legit forget
like i don't have a dad and it's like
i'm such an [ __ ] like
but i just have really that's called
surviving
yes but it was may 4th
the day before our dad's what would have
been our dad's birthday
and my friend abe texted facetimed me
and he's like oh my my dad just sent me
the cutest text
and he sent me a screenshot of what
abe's dad texted him and he was like
claudia's dad's birthday is tomorrow and
i l and like i don't know why that set
me off but it's like
that's you know ellis remembered and he
had never even met
our dad but like it was just so
thoughtful that like there are people
around you who are like
thinking of you and know that those days
are hard for you and that
like destroyed me like for hours i
couldn't even watch
i couldn't watch tv i was in the middle
type no this was before i started
watching
which by the way i finished season three
of and we should get into but just know
you never know what's gonna set you off
and god speed to you because i cried and
i'm good for like another year
it's been like months i think i don't i
can't remember
i'm usually on like a a like twice a
year type of twice a year basis
yeah interesting it's seasonal may is
always tough yeah may and october those
are the big ones but i got through
unscathed so october's coming maybe it's
going to be father's day
oh that's a tough one that could hit me
like a ton of bricks that one really
bothers me
i'll keep you guys posted i agree um but
the bowl type yeah so i just finished
season three i'm only at one season left
they exposed pamela dolan
they um jacqueline like disappeared from
the office
after like her rogue fall issue um
she lost cat lost city council and
sutton is encouraging richard to move to
san francisco
so it's been a lot it's been a lot
okay well i just without giving too much
away like you have a lot to look forward
to
okay okay what are sutton and richard
doing otherwise um just like being rich
and it's amazing and he like he bought
her a sewing machine and she like won't
accept it but then it's like that's what
a partner's for like they lift you up
and like richard has all this money and
he wants to spend it on you son just say
okay
yeah i just couldn't relate i i've
actually found her to be the most
relatable character
but the moment she like moved in with
richard wouldn't use this housekeeper
kept splitting dinners on venmo and
wouldn't accept his 2500
gift from him i've never related to her
less
okay that was a big mistake okay fifth
and final story a little documentary
news we're getting one from pink oh my
god
that's great new amazon prime video
documentary called pink all i know so
far offers a rare glimpse backstage as
she toured the world in 2019 with her
family in tow
so i just want to say like a pink
documentary love to see it
also she just put out a new song also
called all i know so far
that is so [ __ ] good chef's gifts
premium content go listen to it
i'll listen to it on the plane maybe
i'll cry you'll cry oh really like
because it's upbeat like it's also like
a running song a workout song but it's
like
it's so it's almost like that the chorus
of like this is me where it's just like
chill shivers look out cause here i feel
that you know
it's like so it's not down in like it's
not a ballad
but it could still get you just as good
in your feels i'm so excited and
thrilled that she has a documentary
i there's a special place in my heart
for celebrity documentaries
some of them have really changed how i
see people they could change the course
of history
no they really can and i really feel
like five foot two lady gaga's changed
the course of history like i thought it
was the best documentary i'd ever seen
i cannot watch joan rivers piece of work
enough times i own it on youtube so
on my phone every time i'm on a plane i
watch it because like what else am i
doing
um who else's is really good
um i actually really like the justin
bieber youtube like episodic one
i just think they're oh the jonas
brothers happiness begins happiness ends
whatever the whole thing
you should check it out yeah i mean
beyonce's like hbo one was amazing one
of my favorite clips ever
is from that documentary where she's
just like practicing in the car really
quick like a quick vocal warm-up and she
sings listen
from dream girls and it's probably like
the best vocal performance
of our generation and she wasn't even
crying she was in the car and her laptop
was on her lap like
it was it's the crazy i watch that clip
like when i get drunk and like want to
share things on youtube with people
and that's like one of my go-to's lives
rent free in your head along with your
brain
lives rent [ __ ] freight and all
of the taylor swift miss americana all
of her
concert dvds oh katy perry uh part of me
that is one of the greatest
documentaries
celebrity or otherwise she's going
through her divorce from russell brand
she's on this like crazy world tour at
the height of her fame and you just
really get to know her
also one direction also blackpink
i love when it's interspersed like
documentary song
documentary song yeah homecoming beyonce
documentary song documentary song well
in her amazon upcoming amazon prime
video documentary pink all i know so far
streaming may 21st set your calendars
she gives a rare backstage glimpse as
she navigated her history making
beautiful trauma world tour the second
highest grossing world
tour of all time by solo female artist
you know what i i mumbled it because i
couldn't believe what i was reading and
then i didn't know this
oh what is it beautiful trauma world
tour the second highest grossing world
tour of all time by a solo female artist
and what was number one reputation by
taylor swift
was it i believe so how much did it grow
can you look this up actually
okay highest grossing highest grossing
female
world tour yes i do believe it is
reputation or it might be madonna yeah
like
just pink being number two i didn't know
that's what i'm saying about pink
she is such a here she is she's a sniper
from the side
like she just kills it subtly okay wow
yeah so here are all the tours
by male female group everything number
one tour can i guess
of all time is it well is it like the
beatles
i have a few guesses coldplay no jay-z
and beyonce together
taylor swift no ed sheeran's
divided tour you know what i don't even
i don't want the stands coming for me
but
i went to that tour just leave it at
that and that's all i'll say you two
the u2 360 tour oh did they you know
slide free tickets into everyone's
pockets
yep that's the second biggest then guns
and roses
not in this lifetime tour then the
rolling stones a bigger bang tour
then coldplay head full of dreams tour
roger waters
the wall live ac dc black ice tour
metallica worldwide tour
rolling stones no filter tour then
madonna sticky and sweet tour and then
pink beautiful trauma world tour
i would have never guessed that in a
million years then the next two are you
two tours and then the next one is bruno
mars 24 carat magic world tour what are
the reputations then
garth brooks and trisha yearwood's world
tour then the police
then elton john then bruce springsteen
and the e street band
and then taylor swift's reputation tour
that's 19
overall but three three six
solo female all right well evermore will
be number one you know what i would call
those
interesting factoids i know like so much
metallica so much metallica so much
you too yeah i guess there's a reason
why
they were eligible to give everyone a
free album you know you have a lot of
money to do that
yeah or maybe those three albums really
worked and everyone started showing up
at the tours they couldn't get enough do
you think they're like
so embarrassed by that because they
should be they don't look embarrassed
no not at all it's bono yeah
not bon jovi no and not bon iver
don't get it twisted who the [ __ ] is bon
iver it's bony bear
bon iver justin so bon jovi is a man
not a band john jovi and you know yeah
and he's not a band or his journey
no no oh no oh no no so we gotta
hold on to what who's that bon jovi
yeah and what does journey sing don't
stop do you see how that's confusing
even you see how that's confusing sure
so much glee music you know
sure and then like not to get thing make
things crazy but then there's arrow
smith
so similar no but that's liv tyler's dad
yes american idol mm-hmm those were the
great years of american idol by the way
when i was in high school and it was
like liv tyler j.lo yeah liv tyler was
american idol judge
steven tyler excuse me those were good
years and now
steven tyler all he is amounted to is
being the punching bag
for people who like always say about
like middle-aged women who've had
plastic surgery like they look like
stephen tyler like leave steven out of
this 100
he's a nice man he did not sign up for
that he did not [ __ ] sign up for that
yeah um so in conclusion
celebrity documentaries are good pinks
is going to be great
respect being put on pink's name she's
very private which i love about her
because i feel like she's a really good
work-life balance and a very healthy you
know view on the world
but i am looking forward to getting a
glimpse same and i'm just really
wrapping my head around the fact that
beautiful trauma was the second highest
grossing female solo world tour like
that
i just think doesn't get said enough no
she just like keeps her head down and
works [ __ ] hard
that's what happens that's just so crazy
i'll be watching this documentary
because i want to see what it looks like
to be behind the scenes at the
second highest grossing female solo
world tour and like why didn't we go to
that
i remember trying to get tickets i think
i had a scheduling conflict because i
i remember being like you know what i'm
finally at a place where i
can recognize my stand-up for pink and i
and i want to go somewhere
where i can appreciate it no i don't
feel like i was shamed
um i just finally knew myself well
enough to know that that's something
that i would
thoroughly enjoy and then for one reason
or another i couldn't go
what is like the one concert that you
have the biggest like
fomo from because i have like a story
the life of pablo tour for kanye oh yeah
that's one of my favorite albums like of
all time like sometimes i'll just
randomly put it on
and i said to ben i wanted to go i'm
like i'm gonna get tickets he's like no
let me get them for you
and then you know life happens and all
of a sudden we're laying in bed and
you're at the [ __ ] concert
and everyone on my [ __ ] instagram is
at madison square garden and it wasn't
been
it was ben's fault but like i should
have been more on top of it and i
literally didn't talk to him for like a
whole day i was so mad and i literally
think about that all the time how i miss
that and i'm so upset
yeah i went to that concert it was so
good but i also feel like i didn't
appreciate it enough while i was there
because i was mostly there because zach
really wanted to go so i was just like
being supportive and and i enjoyed
myself and i knew some of the songs but
now i appreciate that album so much more
than i did then and so
while i'm glad that i saw it just know
like i didn't even appreciate what i had
well i've been there at concerts where
like i didn't appreciate what was going
on
under really one of the best concerts
i've ever been to was at barclay center
it was john mayer and i've seen john
mayer a million times but this one was
particularly great
because do you know who opened for him
phillip phillips
and that album philip phillips released
after his
win on american idol is criminally
underrated people should be put in jail
for underrating it
yeah it's so good i agree two other
concerts that i wish i went to
obviously taylor swift read because that
became one of my favorite albums of hers
and the second and i remember i watched
it via ben's snapchat stories wishing
like i had gone was rihanna's
anti yes no a hundred percent
and i watch remember when we used to
like go to concerts and put the whole
thing on our snapchat and it's like
who's watching this no
i was watching that on that yeah on
ben's snapchat story don't be ashamed to
watch
no i watched the whole thing he didn't
even have good seats oh shade
no offense like but i watched it um
let's dive into the tv recap segment
which is brought to you by booty by bray
bands your favorite brand
my favorite brand and because i rose and
groaned in the gym this morning i i
really feel as though i can speak
to the magic of booty by bray bands they
are changing the athleisure game with
their high quality durable leggings and
inclusive approach booty by bray band's
leggings sculpt to your body highlight
your curves
and will take your workouts to the next
level with the perfect amount of
compression and support
they are a brand that prides themselves
on on their inclusive approach
eliminating numbers from the shopping
experience because numbers should never
define us
you can experience the booty by bray
band's signature croco skin material
the black croco skin leggings are the
perfect black leggings every woman needs
in their life
designed to last a lifetime and you can
also shop black croco skin bike shorts
which are a spring
summer staple so you worked out this
morning in your booty by bray bands is
that what i'm hearing i did
and i got some new booty vibrant sets
that are in some sickening colors i'm
bringing one set to nashville because
it's like this burnt orange and i just
feel like everyone's gonna be like oh my
god because every time i wear booty by
rare bands
i get most compliments i've ever gotten
in my entire life so not only do i get a
workout where like everything's being
held together but i'm also looking like
the cutest snatcher what more could you
want um well
i could tell you what more you could
want a code for fifteen percent off
using code toast
at booty by braybantz.com that's booty
b-o-o-t-y
by bray bantz n t b-r-a-b-a-n-t-s dot
com
code toast for 15 off let's dive into
the tv recap there's really not much to
say about the real housewives of new
york because it was
it was an in-between episode like so
much of it was the ladies just getting
to the hamptons
like they're really dragging things out
but you know what i really enjoyed it
like sonia and lou
riding on the convertible where was
sonia's luggage i don't know
um it was it was an enjoyable episode
because i'm really liking the cast and
i'm just enjoying seeing
women do whatever but it does feel
really small like when the five of them
were sitting around that reiki healer
i was like damn there's nobody there
they really need one more time and you
know it's a slow episode when it's one
episode
two different healers yes the dog healer
and then sonia's healer and then the
burning man healer yeah that burning man
party did look really fun
amazing i loved so much about it first
of all like ramona is having an amazing
season so far just on
for so many different reasons and even
when they were doing the healing and
everyone was opening up like so deeply i
was getting like nervous for ramona
because like
she's not always she's capable of that
like what is she doing like doing
reiki like at burning man like i'm sorry
yeah but
i thought she she did a pretty good job
lou was like making fun of her after
like
in her face because her voice was being
but at least she respected the process
enough to like
say something semi
constructive yes but i also really feel
like that answer was good because i
think it led me to understand
ramona a little bit more and why she's
so obsessed i have 60 friends
because she she said it she's like her
only family is avery her and mario are
no longer married you know she's like a
really tumultuous relationship with her
parents and then her mom died
upbringing so i actually felt like even
though
luanne was making fun of her i did
understand her a little bit more
and i know that she doesn't usually say
the right thing but i do feel like
for the most part and i know i'm gonna
regret saying this like she is well
intentioned
i i think we are usually wind up there
and i would agree with that
okay so i was just like glad that she
didn't like ruin i was just nervous that
she was just gonna ruin the vibes
because everybody was sharing
so much so deep and everyone really had
i had a new
perspective and new respect for everyone
in what they were sharing i actually
i loved everything about the party
because i love that it like got them
dressed up they were so excited to be in
ramona's backyard
looked unbelievable yeah
like unbelievable yeah i thought it was
really interesting to learn that
ebony's apartment is in tribeca which
means it's
so expensive but that it's paid for by
her ex-fiance yeah
nice nice i love that apartment so much
and i love that she has the king charles
cavalier spaniel
i know and i just like i need her to
stay in that apartment because i know
it's literally elevating the entire show
i think she's moving she won't even
sleep in the bed it doesn't matter i
know she can sleep on my couch but she
has to stay in the apartment it's so
nice
it's so nice and the pups bruno was just
like shook he also was looking at marley
and stuff last night but he was like
bring me back to ebony's place yeah
marley and coco like [ __ ] on the bed
and ramona's house was so funny ramona's
house does look really good
it looks so good when they were doing
some aerial shots like it was looking
better than ever
no in the room that luin god i was like
that's a stunning guest bedroom
yeah so i actually really like ramona's
house in the hamptons i always forget
that she has it
yeah no everything about the episode so
far was very
very good yeah it was just like kind of
boring yeah they need to move the
ball along but it's only the second
episode but they did kind of set the
scene for leah not getting along with
heather i didn't know it was because
it's just leah didn't like that heather
was talking [ __ ] about people on podcast
but not leah that's like not your battle
yeah it's like if luanne can be okay
with it then why is leah so upset with
it also like
i understand the premise of i don't like
a girl who just runs around like sharing
what we did behind the scenes but like
the pirate saint bart's episodes are
from so long ago they're part of like
real housewives
history like talking about what happened
then
has really no bearing on life right now
i agree so
i don't totally get it i feel like
there's more to the story i cuz
they're also so similar heather and leah
i would imagine that they've met other
like that they just have yes
maybe there's more to the story that
just doesn't make sense for watching on
tv
yeah they definitely have met each other
before and just like didn't like each
other they met each other at the
berkshires they were sitting next to
each other didn't look like they even
looked at each other
yeah i just feel like sometimes people
might be too similar yeah but then a
little too different
100 um and then real housewives of
dallas honestly was it was really boring
like they spent
so much of their reunion like looking at
bloopers you know like when people
mispronounce things
it honestly all could have been in one
but the biggest bombshell was obviously
brandy yeah
talking about her pregnancy how she
literally was you know drinking a ton
for the first three months of her
pregnancy because she didn't realize she
was pregnant they did
a bunch of tests the baby is totally
okay but it was like a major concern
um that's so scary it was really scary
and
then this crazy accident that brian's
mom got into where the way she described
the accident
they were hit by an 18-wheeler
semi-truck they
the the the truck
dragged the car then the car flipped and
then
the truck fell on the car
and brinkley had like a broken arm and a
couple scratches and the mom
the brian's brandy's mother-in-law died
like it's a
crazy story she's literally said by the
grace of god like brinkley was
fine it was just a crazy story and then
they brought up this video
which is really why i tuned into the
reunion and i thought brandi had a
really interesting perspective i planned
i plan on watching i just knew i wanted
to wake up early to work out so i had to
prioritize
listening to my body sorry after kind of
like explaining the whole thing
she said like this video was real it's
from 2018 it was intentionally put out
there
to hurt me and we all know who did it
and everyone was like yeah
and then andy was like who like randy he
had no idea what she was saying
and they were like leanne like this is
her go this is her mo like
going after people's families and i
thought that was an interesting take but
i don't
they said that she's so bitter like that
she's not on the show anymore like this
is her act of revenge
i don't know i don't really see what
leanne gets out of it
i don't i wouldn't purport to know what
goes on
in leanne's head um it's confirmed that
the video is from 2018 though and so yes
her and brian are fine
so she knew that the video was from 2018
because he was in scottsdale on a joint
bachelor about red party for his
sister and brother-in-law um and
basically what she said like she's
really struggling with it because she
feels
she's so broken like stephanie said like
she was out of town when it happened and
like
she sent their friend over to go check
on brandi and brandi was sitting in her
nursery in the pitch black holding her
baby hysterically crying like really sad
um but what she said was that like it
was three years ago
she are they kissing in the video yes
okay and they look like they're dating
like they like they know each other but
it was just like a hookup
um what she had said was that basically
brian has been so there for her
these last two years she would be you
know
remiss devastated and heartbroken and
she didn't try and have the same kind of
grace for him that
you know he put out to her so it does
seem like that she's gonna stay with him
and i don't know i'm i'm kind of a fan
of them staying together i don't know i
feel relieved
no i know i just think like i married i
don't know like
if it was me like goodbye like i would
literally kill then but she's already
seen this video she knows about this
video she made peace with
how do you know that isn't that what you
said this video is from a while ago
it's from i don't know if she had seen
it three years ago they didn't make that
clear
oh okay sorry i thought that's what you
meant no i think um she saw for the
first time on social media which is
really hard
got it i don't know i'm just i'm kind of
rooting for them i feel like they
they have like a real marriage and it's
always been like up and down and
i don't know i think that they can get
past it i really do i'm rooting for them
too
and i just thought i had a lot of
respect for how she was very upfront
with like everything and then like the
baby started to cry it was just like all
so sad
it was like do you know what how
overwhelming yeah just it's a lot and
then the covet of it all and having to
be in the hotel room
i'm rooting for brandy i really am i
think she's do you think she's gonna
come back
i don't know i felt like she wasn't but
then after watching the reunion her face
everything head-on i kind of feel like
she could and she should
she should also i feel and i think she
has work to do on her relationship with
tiffany
because they had an interesting
conversation and i do feel like there
could be like a sickening friendship
there i really do
but the cameron of it all with tiffany
like it was the same they just
didn't stop and like
like cameron scream like i love her but
like cameron screenshots like they were
really cringy like all of her paperwork
like
she was basically trying to say like
that something tiffany put up was like
racist towards white people
and it's like twitter like took down the
meme and she's like i have a picture of
twitter taking it down it's like girl
stop like
it was just it was nothing i'm sorry do
they come to any sort of understanding
they hug
okay but then on twitter they were like
being mean to each other again last
night so it was just stupid
got it okay i'm going to watch that
sounds like what i thought it was it was
boring but honestly it wasn't anymore or
any less boring than the real house size
of new york
oh okay yeah um okay let's dive into
your toasters our advice segment where
we give pretty good advice to people who
ask for it and to those who don't
um the advice segment is brought to you
by bruce
the best electric toothbrush on the
market works great
is so affordable compared to other
brushes which can cost over two hundred
dollars
we give out really good advice during
gear toasters but the best advice we
could give you is to get
a bruce join the millions of toasters
who have elevated their teeth brushing
game with the brush
which features six unique modes of
brushing to customize your entire
experience
it comes with a battery life that lasts
four weeks it also comes with a magnetic
charging stand
and a compact travel case all of the
accessories are very elegant they don't
clutter up your sink area it's very uh
kim kardashian approved they also offer
a subscription program so you never
change to forget your
you never forget to change your brush
head again they'll ship you a new
replacement head every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
their electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design and it
comes in trend driven
seasonal colors that look great on your
bathroom counter get 15
off your toothbrush kit and refill plan
when use the promo code toast at
bruce.com
that's 15 off use the promo code toast
at brush.com
love it all right let's dive into deer
toasters i do believe we also
have an update today which i'm very
excited about hi claudia and jackie
hi my boyfriend and i have been dating
for a year and we've been living
together since
august we're still figuring out the
balance of combining our lives and
having some independence
my boyfriend's family has a lake house
not too far from where we live which we
go
to here and there throughout the year
anyways his birthday is in june and i
also have a bachelorette party to attend
in june near his birthday his birthday
falls on wednesday this year so i asked
if he would want to do the lake
with his friends the weekend before so i
could go he said no he wants to do it
the weekend
of his birthday week i asked why he
wouldn't want to pick a weekend where i
can go and he said he shouldn't have to
explain
since since his birthday oh my god diva
he also said
since i have plans already it shouldn't
matter i expressed how i feel
left out sorry i expressed how i feel
left out and he said why
why we can celebrate together on his
actual birthday am i being selfish or
crazy
uh okay this story just got weird at
first i thought he was just being like a
big baby about his birthday like no i
wanted that weekend but it sounds like
he actually wants you to not come
right like it's a boys thing you'll
celebrate wednesday and then you'll be
at your bachelorette party he'll be at
his boys weekend
um are there other girls going are other
girlfriends going is it just going to be
you and his friends in which case like i
do understand him
but i just wish he would communicate
that like it's not bad to say i just
want to be with the boys
yeah but communicate it yeah and also
like if that's what he wants and there's
nothing like
nefarious that's my favorite word during
your toasters it is it's nefarious or is
it not
my favorite word is during deer toaster
layer
because it is it's always layered and
here's the thing you need to evaluate
everything
is in nefarious of course you've got an
issue if it's not nefarious and he just
wants to begin with his boys like
take the weekend off enjoy it like by
complaining but we need communication
no but we also need communication from
her like what's the setup
is it just boys is it girlfriends what
goes down at the lake is there like a
local pub
what goes down at the lake take me to
the lakes where all the poets
went to die but you don't belong are
they going
to see where the poets went to die
because that doesn't sound nefarious
that sounds like a nice bonding
experience amongst men
100 but the way that he's acting like i
want my birthday on this weekend is not
is very childish so that to me is just a
little annoying no but just
maybe you haven't thought yet that he
just wants to be with his boys in which
case you should be supportive
but if there are other girls going and
he's making it impossible for you to
come like that's [ __ ] shystay
agreed hi claudette's jackson doctor for
chairman hi
chasey others would say nefarious some
would say nefarious you're right
next up i'm writing to you with a unique
predicament i feel totally stuck in my
situation
bear with me as i break down the story
of my strange neighbors
my streamers i made that up i didn't
want her getting credit for it
i recently moved into apartment and my
unit is at the end of the hallway
across from me is an older couple who by
all means seemed sweet when i first
moved in this is like the movie the
duplex with drew barrymore and ben
stiller have you seen it
no it is criminally underrated it is the
[ __ ] funniest movie everyone should
watch it
they haven't gone outside their
apartment since last year because of
covid they have every grocery item
delivered trash picked up from the door
and even laundry delivered
because they're stuck inside the house
their doors are wide open but sorry
because they're stuck inside the house
their doors and windows are always open
so when i come when i come in and out of
the hallway they are always flagging me
down to chat
because my unit is at the end of the
hallway i have no choice but to pass
them every time i leave or enter
conversations seem to grow longer and
longer every time i take one foot out my
door which drives me crazy
i try to act rush but they always throw
those crazy long stories on me and i
don't want to be mean by cutting them
off
i just don't have the backbone to say
hey i really gotta go now they clearly
have no interaction with the outside
world and they take it out
all out on me when i honestly don't have
the time for hallway chatter that can
sometimes take up to 15 minutes every
time i leave
that's just the tip of the iceberg since
i moved in i've noticed they've been
weirdly copying things that i do
first off i drink celery juice every
morning after a week of moving in my
neighbors started having celery juice
delivered every morning
when i first moved in i noticed they
liked a specific type of music as soon
as i told them at like taylor swift
all they play now is taylor swift loud
enough so that i can hear when i sleep
in past a certain hour and haven't left
my house yet they text me
hey boo are you okay i hate that they
seem to monitor my every move one of the
weirdest things is that i left my window
open one day when it was really hot and
my neighbor straight up told me that he
took that opportunity to look inside my
apartment
and made all these comments about what
he saw every time i have a friend over
their music immediately turns off and i
know it's because they're trying to
eavesdrop
they have even quoted things i've said
in private conversations
to people within my apartment they're
not afraid to admit it i don't mean to
be a [ __ ] but i hate these neighbors
oh sorry no i hate that these neighbors
seem obsessed with me and are constantly
cornering me with lengthy conversations
every time i step foot out of my
apartment
i can't ignore them trust me i've tried
and what do i do about the obvious
eavesdropping a toaster seeking privacy
and peace i think there's a multitude of
things going on here because at first i
was about to be like girl you are a
[ __ ] like
these people have not left their house
in a year yeah i was just gonna say wear
headphones when you leave
no and like okay give them five minutes
like it's some like it's
it's a nice thing but the music and the
eavesdropping
not being able to have a conversation in
your own home looking into your window
you gotta move yeah that's it's as
simple as moving
yeah and whether or not you like love
your apartment there's a better one
and it doesn't include nosy neighbors i
totally agree because you can't tell off
old people first of all they won't even
understand what you're saying too it's
so disrespectful
yeah you have to move that's it's as
simple and as complicated as that it's
not yeah you know what this is not
layered
i don't see another path forward rather
than moving 100
so pack your bags hit you know
apartments.com
and check it out yeah all right final
one is an
update from the toaster writing and um
oh
so former toaster writing and following
up about my boyfriend that's in the fbi
never post pictures of me
first off i screamed when i heard
claudia read my email and laughed so
hard hearing the advice you ladies are
exceptional
it truly was the reality check i needed
okay so for those who remember her
boyfriend
has like a really serious job in the fbi
and he never posts her on social media
because he's like
just protective and that's just not what
he does and because we
gathered he's probably like seen some
[ __ ] yeah and is like smarter than the
rest of us to know not to put your
personalized and she was just like all
butthurt about it when we literally told
her what a blessing this is like thirsty
thirst traps on instagram for men it's
just like you have no idea what a gift
it is to have a boyfriend who hates
social media 100
so she said you ladies are exceptional
it was truly the reality check i needed
my sober self was so appreciative and
listened and then my drunk self
[ __ ] let loose on him in the middle
of a bar it was so bad
like truly embarrassing thinking back
about it the next day we talked things
through and we were able to discuss
reasons why me not being on his social
media bothered me so much
and it was super beneficial it's been a
month since my blow up and without me
even asking he has created an
instagram handle under his middle name
this past weekend only his close friends
know it's him so you can't find him by
searching his actual name
middle ground i didn't even know existed
and since creating the account he has
posted pictures of him
and our dog it's fine but where am i
just kidding
i'm truly over it and i don't care
plus our dog is the most precious gem of
a canine so i understand
looking back i can hear you both
snatchler
learn your lesson fellow toasters always
follow the steve's advice
signed a dramatic drunk this girl's
funny i'm glad that she can laugh at
herself i i real that's what it is the
beauty of deer toaster sometimes is that
like
it really does take a third party
perspective with no personal interest in
the matter
to give you like a fresh perspective and
i felt like this was actually some of
our best advice
i totally agree it's nice to see things
from someone else's point of view i'm
glad that it all worked
out and also even though like our advice
was just to like appreciate what you
have
sometimes you even if it's still
bothering you yeah you know feelings
sometimes are illogical so if you have
to share that get it off your chest
i'm glad you guys found a path forward
um communication is key again
communication make sure it's not
nefarious period
period period make sure it's not a virus
and you know what i hate when things are
nefarious oh that's when the problem
starts
so that was your toasters if you guys
ever want to write in a problem that
you're having or you want to update us
with some of the advice we've given you
email deartoasters gmail.com and we will
do our best to get all of your inquiries
up on this here stage yes that is our
show it is our last
in studio show of the week tomorrow we
will be coming at you with a podcast
only episode from
what do they call nashville the music
city
from music city um we hope you guys have
a great
day we'll see you tomorrow morning new
episode of the redheads drops tomorrow
morning
so if you're looking for some extra
content the girls will be back together
being hysterical there's also new
episodes of mood with lauren elizabeth
and
margaret joseph's podcast caviar dreams
and raven and alexis raven came on the
podcast
to chat about her wedding mazel tov so
check out all the chosen news network
shows and have a great day you guys
thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found
so whether you listen on podcast store
spotify itunes stitch your public radio
i already catch boxes all the places
where listening to podcasts
find us the morning shows leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are we hope you have an
amazing day say bye theo
bye theo goodbye goodbye